during an appearance on the tonight show
with jimmy fallon duolipa surprised her
80 year old super fan paparicci papa
richie the grandfather recently went
viral on tick tock after his family gave
him tickets to dua's future nostalgia
tour
his reaction was priceless right but not
as priceless as this moment bye everyone
so all right so right now we all need to
be really quiet because seriously it's
being led to what he thinks is the radio
station
uh and what he doesn't know is he's
about to walk onto the tonight show and
meet dooley
all right so all right let's get ready
he's back home with you yeah you come
with me
we'll hear well here when he's here
ready as we're ever gonna be
the first party
first radio ever
pop i will follow you okay well i'm
going to follow okay he's coming through
i think we can hear him
oh my god
hi jim
everyone please welcome papa richie
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
and this is your greatest your
granddaughter yes i'm katie katie how
are you jimmy uh today
80's 22nd birthday it's katie's birthday
happy birthday to you thank you what a
present uh this is right here uh uh now
i i read something that said that you're
one of your dreams is to dance with
duolippa yes yes of course
can we make
can we make that dream a reality
[Applause]
[Applause]